le paysage est dégagé ce soir pour
plusieurs milliers d'habitants de la
cité des 4000 à la courneuve en 8
secondes et dans un grand nuage de fumée
un immeuble de 16 étages et près de 200
mètres de long a été démolie à
l'explosif un seulement spectaculaire
13h06 et 30 secondes à la cité des 4000
à la courneuve dans trente secondes le
coup de barre l'immeuble debussy celui
là près de 200 mètres de long
rayés de la carte la restructuration de
la cité est en marche
aujourd'hui un grand pas le
désenclavement des bâtiments passe par
600 kg de dynamite grand spectacle
les personnalités sont là 13h07 dernière
seconde
l'ensemble du quartier a été évacué il
n'y aura même pas un quart ou a volé en
éclats nous allons même le reconstruire
pour mieux leur est démolie c'est beau
bravo une chute au mètre près une
première européenne
quand un tel bâtiment de mort
j'aurais préféré la garder je n'ai
regretté la barre depuis si je le
regrette d'ailleurs j'ai pleuré quand
c'est tombé quoi auquel j'ai habité au
cinquième étage
et pendant combien de temps 14 à 370
logements debussy s'est terminée dans la
poussière
il faudra quatre mois pour évacuer les
gravats et plusieurs années pour
replanter un nouveau quartier plus
humain